can you create a folder structure for
the project yes you don't need to know
anything about the framework in order to
create the HTML and CSS files that
you'll later be writing can you create a
Dom tree for the page yes using the
structure of the mock-up you can pretty
much figure out what the Dom tree should
look like
can you write HTML that defines the Dom
yes you can if you can figure out the
Dom tree for the page you can start
writing the HTML that will create it can
you assign class names to HTML elements
no you can't not until you have your
framework picked out each framework will
have its own custom classes can you
write CSS not quite not until you pick a
framework and can you test the page well
if you don't have the CSS you're not
going to be able to test it yet